hey when I'm David Griffin now Michael
Medina bring you our first impressions
of one of the most anticipated video
games of all time no not a maybe not
about of all time of 2014 titanfall
Michael I Susan can we talk about the
beta yes that we played on pc v FEC we
do not have Xbox ones at the time so we
did the pc beta was only on xbox one and
pc this is from respawn entertainment
company subsidize a broken or any ward
the modern warfare juggernaut he just
can't get rid of it's just gonna keep
coming trying to spark some new life
into the first person John where I mean
with so many called duties every year we
get new call of duty so was titanfall a
fresh look at the first person shooter
um I'm gonna have to say yes it was
because first of all this is a game that
I've been waiting for four months since
last year obviously and it's obviously I
highly talked about I thought it
definitely was a fresh take initially
with the whole like Titan concept and
stuff you you start to wonder like how
does this play are the Titans clunky
like you to start thinking about like
control you know I'm a huge call of duty
Johnny I am so it's like you know I may
be a playbook too much and I can bear a
little too much to call dude and that's
not fair yeah but this game I felt it
handled well I thought it was maybe a
little touchy at times with the controls
but I had a lot of fun piloting the
Titans yeah I think what's interesting
too is this games trying to I'm not
trying to get dramatic here use
hyperbole and be like you know this is
gonna revolutionize games forever but
you know with all the call duty
franchises let's just let's pull
battlefield into this conversation to
get these really big multiplayer worlds
the games are built for multiplayer
content like map packs you pace what
fifty dollars for format packs like
those like huge money on maps in about a
four and a half hour story that a lot i
remember when i first Adar a little a
benefit of Game of the Year thing you're
like people were like please do not talk
about Paula Deen's up because yeah
because the stories aren't as strong as
like a last of us yeah right Halo or a
bioshock infinite or not like the really
deep story so what they're trying to do
is they're trying to do a multiplayer
and story at the same time now we didn't
get a txt on the beta yeah we just got
to three different modes right let's
talk about the bay a little bit let's
talk about what I guess maybe those some
of the
modes you can play in the bay ok well
there's attrition which is kind of like
a team deathmatch you've got a
domination you know basically just
capturing positions and then you get
like a Titan with last time is basically
you know everybody in a Titan right off
I think this game is very ambitious
first a bit just to be able to try to
tell a story just you know online and
stuffs but I thought in all its
attention on online and stories as
opposed to absolutely absolutely but I
mean I thought the game was fun I like
the concept of it was a lot easier to
control these characters like the
jetpacks the scale err on the side of
the buildings and stuff and it was fun
like how the story plays out we don't
really know we unfortunately I got what
about like two maps I believe yeah and
they were definitely I thought they were
well thought out you know there are
large maps which makes sense you know
when you're using something like a Titan
rice because these guys are didn't feel
too big you always seemed like you were
in action exactly i think some of that
and this is a little controversy some
people don't like it are the bots yeah
there's these guys you're gonna you know
i guess and girls to it you're gonna
kill that seemed almost too easy then
she it's like drone kill it's like oh
it's a bot so i didn't mind it it kind
of populates the world doesn't make it
feel empty it kind of keeps you on your
toes I mean they're kind of they don't
that's smart the AI is not very smart
but I didn't mind the whole bot thing no
the same year I mean it can get annoying
i could see right would after a while
but um no it was good and one of the
things that I really loved about this
game is unlike a call of duty all right
i'm not a big battlefield guy but I just
felt that they do a really good job of
making you feel like you're in the
middle of a war yeah like an amazing job
of that more so than like you know some
of these other games and some people
might argue with battlefield no kind of
feeling and that's cool but I mean I
just loved like I really felt like I was
immersed in this war is just it's
insanity even from the very beginning
like when you're dropped in you know
like you know you're all like kinda like
this you're on the plane waiting it goes
like go go go go go and you all this
jump in you jump into battle as opposed
to just like waiting in like you know
domination let's go you know yeah as
little touches like what I thought were
cool you like you know we get to the end
of a game and stuff and you'd have like
your overtime yeah look at like a back
you wait let go to the ship which I lose
you get to this issue and I didn't
really get a chance to get you until
like towards the end of the beta it's
hard like you gotta like go through all
these different you know max and
everything it's tough plus I thought it
was kind of cool it's kind of like you
know a game again like not to bring up
call duty all the time
but you know you get like perks and
stuff like that they have these things
called burn cards right would you get
about three of them you get to use them
basically when you respond so you can do
things like you can start off in a Titan
you can run faster and things like that
which I think are really interesting
because once you use it it's done right
and I was going to say to I think for a
lot of you out there who are myself
included maybe sometimes intimidated by
call of duty because it is hard there's
so many guys and girls out there they're
like you know about your kill death
ratio and how high is your KD and you
know it's tough like it's intimidating
cuz it's a lot of good players this game
seems a little bit more beginner
friendly yeah if you're going into the
first person shooting genre just to say
that you know these games aren't all
either tough you know you die a lot but
like everybody gets a Titan yeah you
know it's like within a certain amount
of minutes you get it tightened you get
points it's not like you have to get a
10 kill streak to get some ridiculous
thing like you're going to get it
tightened when you're playing the game
so you always have a variable challenge
style which is right good especially for
like a lot of newbies yeah I mean it
could be intimidating so again I really
like this game it was fun good smooth
gameplay couple weeks the the official
game it's gonna be coming out for Xbox
one and PC and i believe it's delayed i
think two weeks till march 25th or
something like that because they're
trying to get the xbox 360 one right so
this is probably the first big title i
want to call it necessarily next-gen
games it's still on but it's all more
systems game it's a very good-looking it
we're playing on PC which is a port of
the xbox 360 so this weren't necessarily
xbox one graphics but it still looked
great absolutely it's a great-looking
game so we're really excited to play
hopefully a couple of weeks for bringing
a review of that we'd see the story I
think it ships with 15 maps I believe so
yeah in 15 maps this is this is a big
game you know let us know if you got to
play the beta key to go for friends
house and check it out what do you think
of titanfall it's called duty you know
if your call duty haters out there you
little wary of this or stay in trouble
I'm in trouble when I give a shot i
would say give this a shot even if you
don't like Call of Duty so they might
bring you back into some online I know
I've been kind of off since it's been a
few years yeah I don't know but it's my
turn me back so as always you can come
find us at thank yo calm it comes upon
us on this YouTube page here think
euro-pro it's gonna come chat with the
dennis michael or myself you know we're
all gamers all you know trying out some
new games just you know she'll Elsa show
us out your favorite games at think hero
i'm at griffin de nom at mr. Michael
Alexis well we also have a Facebook page
that's facebook.com slash think hero
fans we should
give us a like subscribe to this page
spread the word we love TV film video
games everything so yeah we'll see you
soon